i don't want to have a board deciding
what i can do with my body we have to
grow up and stop throwing tantrums like
five-year-olds over a vaccine
it was said to be a heated meeting and
it turned out to be a long meeting last
night the clark county school board
discussed vaccine requirements for staff
a decision did not come out until early
this morning now while trustees approved
the measure to develop a vaccine plan it
does not mean vaccines are required for
all staff right now it also does not
apply to students we thank you for
joining us here at noon i'm hector mejia
and it was certainly a controversial
night for ccsd with tensions boiling
over for several hours during heated
public comments bianca holman is
reporting live with the latest on what's
next bianca
well we spoke with one union a group of
representatives about what have heard
last night they said that there was a
lot of public comment against the vote
but they are happy that they are going
to be able to work with the district on
next step so here's a look at what
happened last night a lot of people
there a lot of people in attendance it
was a heated night lasting for hours a
night filled with public comment experts
and board members the final approval was
5-1 trustee katie williams did not vote
many worry that some school staff
members will quit and some people want
to make sure that those with health or
religious concerns are protected we
spoke with the clark county association
of school administrators and
professional technical employees about
the decision
we realize that the district has the
duty to keep schools safe and open and a
safe working environment for not only
the students but also for staff so we
realize that we also want to make sure
that our members are protected
their rights are protected progressive
discipline is uh adhered to and uh we're
gonna wait and see what plan is proposed
and what they have what their thoughts
are and going forward and we'll address
it when we see it
so another point jeff horn also
mentioned when it comes to the plan was
due process that if someone is
disciplined ensuring the process in the
agreement is followed so since this just
happened last night details are still
being worked out there's no date set
just yet on when vaccines will be
required and of course a doctor jar says
he will again develop that plan with a
lot of input from union reps and the
board members reporting bianca holman 8
news now